the world health organization has warned
against easing covid19 restrictions too
soon
criticizing what it calls a premature
rush
back to full normality a number of
countries across europe are
significantly relaxing their rules
that's despite
rising numbers and concerns about the
highly contagious delta variant
the who insists the pandemic is not over
yet
and further waves of infection could
surface
later in the year all of the countries
of the americas we still have nearly one
million cases a week one million
a week you know it's not it's it isn't
over
um uh and the same in europe in the
european region we have half a million
cases a week
it's not like this thing has gone away
so i sometimes have this sense that
everyone thinks it's all over
uh we're just getting on and and to an
extent i understand the sentiment
i understand why people want to feel
that way but for a lot of the world
uh unfortunately this thing is only
getting started
we just need to be a little more patient
remember last summer where we had
everything got good
and then everyone kind of relaxed and
then we kind of arrived in
september october and ended up in huge
trouble but i think that's
where we're going again with a much more
transmissible variant this time around
well the delta variant is causing
concern on both sides of the atlantic
shortly we'll speak to our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott first
though to sonia gallego in london
where almost all covert restrictions are
due to be lifted
in two weeks time song of the who as we
heard there
is warning against lifting restrictions
too soon but in england they're pressing
ahead
how's that decision being received
well it certainly seems to be a mixed
reaction
and judging from the prime minister's
announcement on monday
evening that if the if england would
pass the four tests that were set on on
the 12th of july to go ahead
with the lifting of those restrictions
however that was caveated by
the chief medical officer and the chief
scientific advisor who was standing
on either side of him uh still
maintaining cautions saying that they
would still uh
be inclined to wear masks in indoors and
in crowded areas as well
so sort of setting up a kind of mixed
message as well now the prime minister
is keen that
what he doesn't want to do is for this
to be
mandated by legislation to make it a
question
of personal responsibility uh fair
enough and that's also been educated
and been underlined by the health
secretary as well
but the problem that the medical
community the scientific
community have with this is the fact
that the danger is is that
people could get a little bit too
comfortable with the idea that perhaps
the vaccination
program has been a hundred percent
successful
not the case they are still urging a lot
of caution with this we know that
uh the vaccines have been uh mostly
successful against the variants that
have been
uh popping up however the problem is is
that once you do
remove the need to have masks which is
a a an issue that people have been
mostly encouraged to continue afterwards
if you talk to people around here
they're still sort of very much
on the idea of like continuing to
mention to wear them
but with all of that in mind they could
open up the danger that england could
become
a hot uh pot for uh new variants popping
up variants that could
possibly be more immune or resistant
to the very successful uh vaccine
program that
uh the the uk has undergone
well even given these concerns the the
british governments
uh seem determined to keep uh full steam
ahead with their plan we've heard the
health secretary in the last hour or so
even the education secretary determined
to push ahead with these restrictions
it's impossible to see into the future
especially where this virus is concerned
but
has the british government at least
acknowledged that
they may need to reimpose some of these
restrictions or
is it just continue regardless and
see what happens
well the message really from the british
government is that look
covet is here uh yes we have the
vaccination program but now
the emphasis seems to be towards living
with that risk and the fact that society
cannot possibly
inoculate itself against any risk for
example you know even though there are
road accidents
people still go out drive you just make
sort of
cautious measures to try and prevent
those things
however the opposition uh party and also
echoing voices from the medical
community is saying that
fair enough of course that there isn't
sort of
you know that you need to move ahead but
there need to be
measures in place in order to stop uh
this getting out of control once again
um the mask wearing the medical
community uh
acknowledged that it is a relatively
unobtrusive way
of trying to keep uh safety uh
and prevent um numbers from going
further up
don't forget of course also that numbers
of covet have gone
up quite a bit in the tens of thousands
in the last week alone
so what they want to do is see measures
put in place
carefully guarded opening up towards the
society but
it seems to me that the government seems
well intent on pushing ahead
unless it says that they are confronted
with evidence that would prove otherwise
okay well we'll keep a close eye on that
but for now sonia gallego reporting live
from london thank you very much
indeed let's bring in our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott she joins
us
from washington d.c uh kimberly like the
uk the u.s enjoys a fairly high rate
of vaccination are there similar
concerns
in the u.s about the fast reopening of
uh general life given that there's quite
a lot of vaccination there but not
everyone
is taking up the offer of those vaccines
what's really a concern is this past
holiday weekend that we've had here in
the united states the independence day
holiday
where a record number of americans both
vaccinated and unvaccinated were
traveling and
going into this holiday weekend we know
that already
50 percent of states in the u.s had a
spike in cases as well as
hospitalizations due to covet 19
that delta variant apparently driving a
lot of those among the unvaccinated
and the concern is with this holiday
weekend that we've just experienced here
in the us that
not only the increased travel but also
the social gatherings are going to see a
spike in cases
in the coming weeks so public health
officials really on the alert for that
right now and we should also point out
that
this was a milestone that the u.s
president joe biden had hoped would be
somewhat celebratory and set that goal
of
70 percent of americans getting at least
one dose
by the july 4th holiday they came close
but
not quite enough and that is due to the
vaccine hesitancy that we're seeing
not just in the u.s but in other parts
of the world as well
and so this is the grave concern because
what we're seeing and what we're hearing
according to the data
is that when it comes to these spikes in
cases not just in hospitalizations but
also
in deaths according to the top
infectious disease specialist dr anthony
fauci
99 of those deaths are among the
unvaccinated in the united states
so if there's still this issue with
covert and people aren't planning to
to get vaccinated i mean what does the
the u.s government do now what can it do
now because let's not forget
the the political system in the united
states there is a federal government but
all the states are really in charge of
what happens and if they don't want to
force people to get vaccinated
tough yep that is exactly how it works
in the united states strong states
rights uh
in many cases that supersede the federal
government and so
this is the challenge for the white
house and for joe biden
so he's going to be making an address
we're expecting one in the coming hours
around
1845 and he will be making a renewed
vaccine push
what a key component of the u.s
government's federal response has been
has been education and meeting people
where they are
taking novel approaches to trying to get
people vaccinated because they are
concerned that there is going to be a
spike
due to the delta variant so not only is
the president
going to talk about that he's also going
to have an update from his covet 19
medical team and response team prior to
his speech
but not only is the president going to
be pushing for
americans to get vaccinated but he's
also trying to make sure that
the economy that was hurt so badly a
year ago that it
also doesn't feel the effects of a spike
in cases and so
he's going to be pushing his
infrastructure plan as well
as he tries to get americans back to
work okay kimberly hawker there live
from the white house kimberly thank you